good ready for what's coming
[Music]
Jackson storm is part of the next
generation of high-tech research rookies
in place of Jackson's Tom Jackson storm
storm in a class of his own hey champ
it's got a good run you have no idea
what a pleasure it is for me to finally
beat you did you say meet or beat I
think you heard me enjoy your retirement
you'll never be the racer you once were
you can't turn back the clock kid but
you can wind it up again
the reefing world is changing treadmills
wind-ups virtual reality still working
on that and interactive race simulation
you have crash we got some work to do I
am so excited that I get to train you
visualize beating
[Music]
the beach ate me every week veteran
recent retired to make room for these
younger faster research you given any
paparazzi you'll never be as fast to
storm but you can be smarter
good luck out there - you're gonna need
it I decide when I'm done
you are not winning this
I'm down them for you storm
[Applause]
you are about to become the biggest
brand in racing movie deals infomercial
product endorsement the Tao do you think
you're famous now will be rich beyond
belief
mr. Serling what is this about your
legacy every time you lose you damage
yourself
I'm sorry your racing days are coming to
an end
we can only hope that this race today
wasn't it last I decide when I'm done
hi feelings I can't go out on the track
and do the same old thing if no work
buta there is this James man you know
what I did why I don't know I got
nothing
I am so excited to train you I like a
challenge huh
I call you my senior project on your mod
not at the beach ate me Jackson store
set a new record today when he pulled
off the fastest lap ever recorded
hi in the latest record storm society
even any not gonna clean this is my last
chance
fruit laugh if I lose I never get to do
this again
don't fear failure be afraid of not
having the chance you have the chicken I
used to watch you on TV flying through
the air you seemed so fearless I wish I
knew what that felt like
[Music]
you'll never be as fast to store but you
can be smarter than him
Racing is the reward not to stock
chances of winning are 95 points to
success
that way
and now a geeky child special look at
cutie Pixar's Cars three let's do this
thing
[Applause]
it's Jackson storm for the win evil you
have no idea what a pleasure it is for
me to finally beat you oh thanks I know
did you say meet or beat I think you
hurt me I can't do the same old thing it
won't work then change it up try
something new you know what I do what I
don't know
I got another I that is great
self-motivation did you come up with
that prepare to rape whoa we need to
loosen those ancient joint there you go
I decide when I'm done come on logical
left turn right to go left I definitely
can defend his meat a star
[Applause]
you
[Music]
2% lower mad coefficients
I think this increase downforce
only 8% higher top speed
[Music]
get ready for what's coming
more speed more horsepower
more of everything
[Applause]
you'll never be the racer you once were
[Applause]
you can't turn back the clock kid but
you can wind it up again
you
[Applause]
[Music]
you will never be the racer you once
were accept it well why can't we retire
I decide when I'm done Jackson storm is
part of the next generation of high-tech
racers we're number three for the rookie
sensation
you'll never be as fast but you can be
smarter you need my help mr. McQueen
I'm coming for you storm
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]